you know I mean one I think obviously uh
there are certain people in the body
Administration you should be impeached
right the orcas has clearly violated
itself of office I think Garland is
violated his oath of office uh I don't
know if any of these guys have done
something criminal but certainly if you
reveal something criminal even if you're
a very powerful official maybe
especially if you're a powerful official
you should suffer criminal consequences
because of it
all right it's day three of three here
in Washington DC I'm still Dave Rubin
this is still Ruben reporting joining me
today is the junior senator from Ohio
and the new guy in this crazy town JD
Vance welcome back to the Reuben report
how are you good first time we've sat
down in person we've done this digitally
a couple times uh you are the new guy in
town how are they treating you man you
know it's not too bad I'm having a good
time and uh the thing I've learned about
DC is that yeah it is the swamp and yeah
the crime rate is out of control you saw
of course the news would happen with
Rand Paul staffer which is just awful
thank God he's going to be okay yeah the
work of the Senate despite the fact that
Republicans are in the minority still
actually precedes the pace and we're
able to get some things done we've
killed a couple of very bad bite
Administration nominees
um you know we've gotten some good
legislation I think starting to move
through the Congressional process Biden
will probably veto a lot of it but
um or at least getting some things done
and at the very least we'll Force Biden
to answer for some of his veto decisions
over the next couple years do you feel
like a politician now because for people
that for people that know you and we'll
link to the original interview so they
can if they don't know they can check
out your bio I mean you are clearly not
what a general politician is thought of
yeah no no I don't feel like a
politician I mean eventually I assume
that I will or at least I'll have to
start saying I'm a politician once you
run for office you have staff members so
I guess so yeah eventually you start to
feel like a politician uh but no I mean
I I guess I I still feel the sense of
all about it right it's very easy I
think especially when you're
conservative you're just so frustrated
with what happens in DC it's very easy
to get cynical about politics written
large but when you walk through the
halls of Congress and you see you know
oh there's John F Kennedy's desk there's
Richard Nixon's desk and you realize
that a lot of the great and bad moments
of American History happen which and
what is a pure new office it's hard not
to feel some sensible on it
um and I think that when you're a
politician you probably don't feel that
at all you file you feel just entitled
to it I hope that never happens to me
yeah that's going to be the trick right
to make sure that it never gets old so
one one of the things that I've been
saying for a couple months is that I
sense the Republicans Maybe
starting to do the right thing it feels
like it's happening I sat down with
McCarthy yesterday he laid out an actual
agenda I sense from all the guys that
I'm talking to the guys and gals that
I'm talking to in the Senate Congress
that it might actually be happening do
you believe that the Republicans can get
something done and that the the
never-ending swamp and deep State and
all that just won't expand and eat you
all up and all of that yeah I mean I
feel optimistic about it but it's going
to require some more uh some more work
and some more progress I think obviously
the guys in the house because they have
the gabbos right they have the majority
they have investigatory Powers I think
we're going to learn a lot about what's
going on with the Department of Justice
I think we're going to learn a lot about
why the Attorney General is harassing
political opponents instead of doing the
job of law enforcement I think we may
even see some consequences for some of
the people who have done some some
things wrong what would that look like
to you because I've been asking
everybody about that that we do the
hearings we find how people lie under
oath and sort of nothing happens what
would consequences actually look like
yeah I mean one I think obviously there
certain people to buy Administration you
should be impeached right Marcus has
clearly violated his oath of office I
think Garland is violated his oath of
office I don't know if any of these guys
have done something criminal but
certainly if you reveal something
criminal even if you're a very powerful
official maybe especially if you're a
powerful official you should suffer
criminal consequences because of it but
I think even just knowing what's going
on is a big part of the equation here
and we still have no idea behind the
scenes what's really gone on you know
just take one example right uh when when
the Department of Justice was harassing
parents who are peacefully protesting
last year critical race Theory being
taught at their schools
um what decision was made who made it
was it motivated by political
persecution was it just an innocent
albeit terrible mistake knowing the
answers to these questions is something
the American people have been totally
closed off of so that's where you'd say
if Garland wrote it himself and I guess
it's maybe a little unclear who actually
wrote the memo that that it's it's
unclear who wrote the middle it's
unclear who directed it but yeah I mean
you're the attorney general and you're
sticking your law enforcement officials
after parents for peacefully protesting
that to me is a criminal act right you
have to suffer consequences to that but
you know we'll see and that's that's one
of the good things
um I think dismantling some of these
bureaucracies is a really core part of
this I do think you're going to see in
the debt ceiling negotiation this is you
know my colleagues in the house they
really have a pin on this but I think it
would look like really defunding some of
the more woke sides of the bureaucracy
and I'd say it that includes the
Department of Defense where you have a
lot of the senior leadership not the
troops but the senior leadership the
Department of Defense has gone really in
for a progressive social agenda do you
believe that there's really a chance to
do that I mean this is one that you hit
hard how it's how it's affected our
military specifically uh this one in
particular I do think it's possible
because here here's here's the thing a
lot of these ridiculous Dei
bureaucracies within the federal
government they cost money okay and so
the debt ceiling negotiation is a
perfect opportunity for us to say look
we're not going to fund these things
it's good policy it's also a good
budgetary sense and so yeah I do that
there's some some chance of progress do
I think we're gonna get everything no of
course not right I'm a realist but I do
think that we're going to be in a much
better position with a much less
well-funded Dei bureaucracy federal
government so I want to get to some
specific stuff that you're doing and
obviously East Palestinian especially uh
but but one more generally I told you
right before we sat down that I'm
sitting down with about 20 Republicans
we finally got one Democrat to at least
respond to us but of course it was a no
but 19 or so did not even respond at all
sure you mentioned one guy who maybe we
could sit down I don't know if he's even
want his name mentioned right here but
how's that going for you are you able to
find some Democrats that you can work
with and talk to and that sort of thing
yeah you know absolutely the way that I
put it is that there are specific issues
where you can find some Democrats that
you agree with you know on the energy
issue for example I think you know some
of the folks in West Virginia are not so
supportive of Joe manchin being
anti-energy so we can maybe apply some
pressure to permitting reform we happen
to think by the way David the main
reason why we have inflation is an
energy Supply issue we've really
destroyed the American base of energy I
think that's as important as all the
other drivers of inflation uh maybe the
single most important issue so yeah I
keep asking everybody is it is it
intentional or is it ineptitude do you
think
yeah you know man it's a very good
question I don't have a good answer yet
I I I tend my bias is always never
assume malice or stupidity is a good
enough explanation I do think you have
some pretty dark figures within the bite
Administration who are doing a lot of
bad things but I think the way that they
have so much power is probably
incompetence rather than malice and the
senior officials but I don't know right
that's part of the reason why these
investigations are so important is we
need to understand what's driving what
motivates the senior leadership of the
federal government yeah all right so
let's get into some of the specifics
that you're dealing with so obviously
he's Palestine so this this accident
happens sure and then really nobody
outside of Ohio and then you know a
couple people on Twitter I guess were
talking about it for the first 10 days
then finally it bubbled up people
started talking about it you obviously
were down there and showing what's going
on with the water and all that but now
two weeks later or three weeks later
we're not talking about it again so I I
guess give me an update and how how bad
was the response by this government yeah
so this is a big risk right as people
forget about it the politicians and the
cameras stop showing up and so everyone
goes home uh and that would be really
bad for the people of East Palestine way
that's what they're terrified of right
is they're going to be forgotten yeah
there are a few different things going
on so in the initial stages of the
cleanup both the bite Administration and
Norfolk Southern almost couldn't be
bothered to do the things they needed
Norfolk Southern is the train company
yeah that caused the crash uh it's like
whack-a-mole what I found over the past
eight weeks is every two weeks it's
something new so five weeks ago I would
have told you Norfolk Southern needs to
get off its rear end and actually get
this cleanup finished because they bear
responsibility for three weeks ago I
would have told you that the EPA was
making it harder for Norfolk Southern
Norfolk Southern was starting to do what
they needed to do but the EPA was making
it harder for them and that's kind of
been the the way that our offices
approach it is look each problem let's
just try to solve each discrete problem
because that's the job of a senator is
to solve problems for your constituents
um what I worry about over the next two
big things that I worry about for the
people of East Palestine number one is
we have to provide the long-term health
screening right when you talk to people
in East Palestine they're not worried
they drink the water and they're going
to drop that tomorrow they're worried
their grandkids are gonna drink the
water for 10 years and develop a rare
form of cancer there is no bureaucracy
there's no this is crazy to me something
I didn't know a month ago there was no
apparatus within the federal government
all of the CDC and public health
bureaucracy to test for chronic exposure
to Blues we just don't have the
capability of the federal government
right now and so we're trying to what is
it that the EPA does that if not if not
test water that's almost glowing when
you put a stick in it well they they
test it their their argument is they
test for acute toxins right they can
tell you whether you know you're going
to drink this water and there are toxins
at a level that are going to cause
sickness the next day yeah they have no
real apparatus to test for chronic
exposure and that's the big that's the
big problem here so number one is you've
got to do the long-term health screening
for the people of East Palestine and
again they're terrified they're going to
be forgotten here's the other crazy
thing Dave so imagine you're a farmer in
East Palestine you grow chickens you
sell farm fresh eggs you sell hay
because anybody want to buy your stuff
right if you're at East Palestine what
about if you paid off your house you've
been living there for 40 years and the
home value is is falling through the
roof by 50 so we're gonna have to deal
with the economic Devastation of this
and I hate to say
um I think the by Administration doesn't
care about this issue because they know
the people of East Palestine are not
their voters and we have to make them
care and that's one of the things I have
to focus on not just for the next few
weeks for the next few months doesn't it
really suck to to believe that that you
want like like Trump goes down there and
to me that's Trump at his best it's like
No Nonsense he's there for the people he
gave away stuff he brought attention to
it can you contrast that within about
three days later than uh than Pete
Buddha judge shows up I I suspect the
reaction was a little bit different uh
he looks like if I he looks like my
toddler it's sort of the hard hat dress
up that's right visual reaction when I
saw him uh I guess you know just
partially the young looking guy
going into town
but but the the the crazy thing is the
complete lack of earnestness or urgency
from the president United States I can't
think of if this I really don't believe
if this had happened in a community with
a democratic interest group that you
would have had complete ignorance
complete refusal to show up to show any
real leadership for the bite
Administration but that's really what
we've seen and I hate to say that I do
think that the you know
whether it's biting himself with the
people who work for him you never know
with Joe Biden whether it's actually him
you know who's who's driving the wheel
none of us actually know
um but the the problem is they have this
friend enemy distinction in politics and
you've really seen this with the way on
after political opponents but if you're
not on the right side of their political
Ledger they don't feel like they have an
obligation to do you I think it's a
complete inversion of constitutional
government in our country but it's
unfortunately what we've seen a lot in
the past couple years yeah as I'm sure
you know I mean yesterday was it was
yesterday the day before Matt taibi was
testifying about government overreach
and the IRS literally showed up at his
house during the hearing I mean it's
crazy this is this is weird yeah I mean
it really is Banana Republic stuff right
it gets thrown around too much but you
know if you're you're Matt taibi I don't
know and he's a lefty yeah that's the
point he's a lefty but of course he said
things that are offensive to the Biden
regime yeah and I and I use that word uh
specifically I do think it's it's a bit
of a regime uh but look you have are you
you have agents of the government
showing up at your house who have
subpoena power over you have the power
to take your money away and that is that
happens when you dare speak up against
government Authority that is not the
United States of America but again it is
what we're seeing a lot from the by
demonstration and it's not just that I
mean you see what pro-life activists I
mean we could go through the number of
examples where the by demonstration just
conveniently just coincidentally happens
to send government agents against their
political opposition but it happens so
frequently that I don't think many
people who are paying attention are
blind to what's that actually go on so
we have somewhat limited time here so
let's just do a couple of the other ones
that you're talking a lot about uh let's
Ukraine Russia I don't know that we can
do somewhat quickly but sure but I I
think your basic position is hey we're
endlessly funding something that there's
no end game here yeah is that pretty
much the simplest version of it there's
no in-game and nobody's articulated what
we're actually trying to accomplish so
you really ask the people who are
driving our Russia Ukraine policy what
are we trying to do nobody can actually
tell you I think it's really telling by
the way you know I've endorsed president
Trump
um but it's really telling to me that
both president Trump and Ron DeSantis
the two clear front-runners for the
Republican nomination nobody else hasn't
really any chance both of them are
saying we need to be a little bit more
cautious about our Russian Ukraine
policy and yet the entire establishment
in Washington has taken the opposite
view I think it's a terrible mistake but
let me sort of make one very important
Point here the argument that I make
about Russia Ukraine is that there is a
clear conflict between our interests in
East Asia and our interests in Eastern
Europe so if we want to prevent the
Chinese from invading Taiwan cutting off
access to semiconductors tanking our
economy making it possible for us to
manufacture modern weapons of war that's
what an invasion of Taiwan would do we
need to focus on East Asia weapons that
we are sending to Ukraine mean weapons
that we cannot send to Taiwan and
because America doesn't manage Factor
enough of its own artillery enough of
its own missiles there is a clear
conflict it's not it is unfortunately a
zero-sum dynamic the more we focus on
Ukraine the more empowered China is in
East Asia and anybody who ignores that
reality is not being serious about the
trade-offs all right unfortunately we
only have time for one more so I'll let
you choose it we can either do ESG big
Tech or or border and fentanyl which
obviously I know is let's let's do big
Tech okay yeah so big Tech I mean are we
going to fix any of this Elon obviously
is at least loosening some of it and
we're getting a little more info uh but
yeah so this is another area where I
actually you know this is one of the few
places where there are enough Democrats
where you might actually be doing it be
able to do something big here in the
Senate
um on the house side I think that
they're you know they're they're going
in in interesting directions too but you
know to me I continue to believe that we
have to think about this as an
Anti-Trust problem the technology
companies are individually too powerful
within their markets and what they have
ended up ended up doing is impose using
this ideological regime from the top
down and look this is a little bit weird
I think for a lot of conservatives a lot
of people who believe in the free market
right they say well these are private
companies and my counter argument to
that Dave is always well they're private
companies but they've achieved their
Market power through an unbelievable
accumulation of government savers of
illegal carve outs of liability
protections so these are behemoths
created by the power of the US federal
government and I think they can only be
curtailed by the power of the U.S
federal government so I really think
that that you know we need to go into
trust Buster mode break up some of these
companies make them less powerful some
of this even the threat of antitrust I
think is making these companies less
ideological uh and less Progressive
obviously Twitter is I think a really
good thing I think what Elon did is
frankly heroic but you still have
Facebook you still have Google which is
probably the single biggest problem I
think the threat of action is making
these companies a little bit less crazy
but I think real action would restore
some sanity to our process one thing and
I know we're a little short on time here
but one one quick thing on this so the
way that Google is most powerful you
maybe have heard this so stop me if you
had is it really buys other people are
watching this too so sure okay
um but it really biases fundraising to
Democrats over Republicans so if you
look at the way that Gmail filters
Republican fundraising emails versus
Democratic fundraising bills I just went
through campaign man that's how you pay
for the TV advertisements that reach the
middle of the road voters that every
person needs even in a deep red state so
if Google is biasing their own email
client to left-wing activists that's
going to have major ramifications for
our political system I think it already
has I think it's one of the reasons
frankly Blake lost in Arizona I think
it's one of the reasons personal didn't
do as well in Georgia is because the
massive fundraising Advantage the left
hands if you don't fix that problem you
can't send good people to Washington the
best you're going to get is frankly
establishment low Hearts it'll do
anything the worse you're going to get
is far left Democrats to actually have a
real America first movement you have to
solve the big Tech fundraising problem
all right this was somewhat brief but
we'll do it again and and my challenge
to you always will be that you gotta
still be excited when you walk in there
because I can sense a lot of it people
aren't and that is part of the problem
yeah agreed thanks Dave good to see you
man yeah if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell